Transcriber: maira sami
Gözden geçirme: TED Translators admin
Herkese Merhaba.
yıl 1976 annem ve Babam tanışıyorlar.
Ikisi de yermi yaşların başında iki genç.
Birbirlerinden hoşlanıyorlar ve
evlenme kararı alıyorlar.
Aynı yıl evleniyorlar.
Çok güzel her şey harika.
Çok güzel giden bir ilişkileri var.
bir iki sene sonra.
Aşklarının meyvesini olarak.
Bir çocuk yapmak istiyorlar.
Fakat çocukları olmuyor.
Doktora gidiyorlar.
Doktor diyor ki:
"Hayır herhangi bir sorun yok
sadece zamanlı olacak bir şey
biraz zamana bırakmanız lazım."
Tabi FM bu kadar ilerlememiş o zamanlar.
Yaşım da çıkı birazcık.
Bir süre bekliyorlar.
İkisi birlikte çok geziyorlar,
eğleniyorlar, her şey çok güzel.
Böyle yedi sene geçiyor.
Yedi sene karı koca ve çok çocukları seven
annem yuva oğretmeni aynı zamanda.
Bir çift fakat çocukları olmadığı için.
Bir kararı alıyorlar ve diyorlar ki:
"Biz neden evlat edilmiyoruz.
O da bizim evladımız olur,
biyolicik olarak annesı babası olmayız.
Ama bizim canımızın bir parçası olur
o da diyorlar."
Sanırım o sırada ben bunu duyurum ve
kıskanıp geliyorum.
Annem hamile olduğunu oğreniyor.
Yedi sene sonunda harika bir sevinç.
Herkes çok mutlu, bir şenlik havası.
Annem çok güzel bir hamilelik geçiriyor
fakar doğum da hiç beklenmedik
bir komplikasiyon meydana geliyor ve
omzum, sol omuzumun sinirleri izilerek
dünyay'a geliyorum, kısmi bir felçle.
Beni annemın yanından alıyorlar,
tetiklerim yapılıyor.
Testler yapılıyor tabiki.
Annemin yanında döndüğüm zaman.
Annem yılardır beklediği, ona kavuşmak
için dakaları saniyeleri saydığı.
Çocuğuna kavuşuyor, ve onu koklarken,
diyorlar ki: "maalesef çocuğunuz kısmi
felç'le dünyaya geldi.
Bir engelli çocuğunuz ve hayatı boyunca
bununla yaşayacak."
Şimdi annem için bütün duygularını
aynı anda yaşandığı bir durum.
Annem düşündük ten sonra,
şoyle bir karar veriyor.
"Ben yılardır bu kokuyu duymak için,
zaten çocuk sahibi olmak istiyordum
ve çocuk sahibi oldum,çocuğum kocamda ve
sağlıklı, nefes alıyor diyor ve
bundan gerisi de, en kolay kısmı diyor."
Ve durumu kabulenip benimle
uğraşmayı başlıyor.
Tabiki çocukken çok tedaviler ve sağ yere,
kolumun gelişmesi için
Kolumun gelişmesi için.
Bir şeyleri kavrıyabilmek tutabilmek için
tedaviler görüyorüm.
Evde de inanılmaz derce de,
büyük bir öz güvenli büyütünyorum.
Bana her şeyi inanırsam,
yapabileceğımı söyleniyor.
Annem, Babam, Yakınlarım,
inanırsan yaparsın.
Senin hiç bir şeyin eksik değil.
Evet fiziksel anlamda bir engellin var.
Ama gerçekten istiyorsan,
yapamayacağın hiç bir şey yok.
Diye beni gaza getirip cam
sildiriyorlardı falan.
Tabiki şaka ama gerçekten,
bu öz güvenli büyüdüm.
Evde her şey çok güzel.
Kendimi gayıt güveniyorum.
Evet ama okula başlama çağını geliyorum ve
evden çıkıp en küçük komin olan.
Aslında küçükken tanıştığınız,
ilk topluluğa giriyorsunuz.
Sosyaleşeceğiniz ilk yer belki de,
okula başlıyorum.
Çocuklar maalesef çok acımasız bu konuda.
Öz güvenim tavağın ken, ben her şey
yapabilirim, sizden biriyim derken.
Beni kendilerin den biri olarak,
görmediklerini farkediyorum.
Kısman dışlandığımı hessediyorum.
Bakışlar, onlar dan farklı olduğumu,
hessettiriyorlar çünkü çocuklar.
Tabiki bunu üzülüyorüm,
bunu hep annemle paylaşıyorum.
Bana böyle baktılar.
"hayır senin için önemli değil,
sen sadece kendinden sorumlusun,
ve yapabileceklerini hala
yapabilir durumdasın,
kimseyi aldır eşitme diyor."
çocuklar beni oynatmıyorlar,
sınıf arkadaşlarım.
Kızlar ip atlar, siz de bilirsiniz,
küçük ken ilk önce zıplarlar.
Sonra baran da atarlar.
Bu çok popüler bir oyun ve
tüm pöpüler kızlar, bu oyun oynar
Ilk okul da.
Ben tabi baran da atamadığım için
beni oynatmıyorlar.
Beni oynatmadıkları kısmı ayrı.
Fakat aslında benim en çok içerlediğim ve
ağırıma giden kısım"sen yapamazsın,
sen oynayamazsın." demeleri.
Bunu duyduktan sonra,
beni en çok kıran şey bu oldu.
Hayatımda ilk, aslında dönüm noktam
bununla ilgili.
Kendim le barışıkken,
her şeyi yapabilirim diye düşünürken.
Biri bana sen yapamazsın dedi.
Bunu duyduktan sonra,
inanılmaz ağladım çok kırıldım.
Ama sonra durdum ve düşündüm,
dedim ki-Hani ben her şeyi yapabiliyordum.
Neler yapabileceğimi düşündüm bu konu da.
Evde kendimi düzenlikler kurdum.
Ipe duvar dan kapıya bağladım.
Üstün den atladım, düştüm.
bam bom sesler geliyor salon dan.
Annem geliyor ne oldu kızım diyor.
Ben diyorum ki:"anne işte kendi kendimi,
ip atlıyorum falan diye geçiştiriyorum."
Ertesi gün okula gidiyorum,
o baran diye atıyorum düşerek.
Ama onlar la birlikte oynuyorum.
Ilk kabulanme deneyemi buydu aslında.
Sosyaleşmek için gerçekten yapmak,
kendini kabullendirme aşaması.
Böyle başladı benim için.
Sonrasında tabi bunlar azalarak,
devam ediyor.
Insanlar size tanıdıkça,
durum farkılaşıyor.
Kendinizi farklı şekiler le ispatlamayı
başlıyorsunuz ve grupları dahil
olabiliyorsunuz.
Yada olmak istemediklerenizi olmuyorsunuz.
Orta okul liseyi ergenlek çağı tabiki.
Herkes olduğu gibi bana da,
Zor geçen bir çağı oldu.
Kendimi beğendirme çabası ayrı.
Sonrasında üniversite ve
üniversite bitirdiğim zaman,
herkes ten istenen iyi bir iş bulmayı.
Bir şirket te çalışmak kısmını geldim.
Bunun öncesinde okul dan mezun olduğumda,
benim büyük bir hayalim vardı.
Araba kullanmak.
Bana kullanamzsın dediler,
tek eller le araba kullanamazsın.
Tabi biz iki elle kullanamıyoruz,
sen nasıl kullanacaksın gibi.
Yorumları duydum ama bunu da inanmadım.
Çünkü ben bunu yapabilirdim ve
inaıyordum.
O arabayi kullanacağımı inanıyordum.
Sonrasına bir ehliyet kursuna gittim.
Bana dediler ki:"engelli rapör
alman gerikiyor, otomatik vetis araba
kullanabilirsin, eğer alırsan." dediler.
Tamam dedim hemen engelli
rapörumu aldım, götürdüm,
Deriksiyon derslerI ve değer dersleri
birincilik le bitirererk ehliyimi aldım.
Ehliyeti aldıktan sonra işe başladım.
Dönemde hemen arabamı aldım kendime.
Harika bir duygu.
Öz güven patlaması yaşıyorum.
Işe girdim mezun olur olmaz bir işe girdim
ve benim engelli olduğumu bilmiyorlardı.
Sonrasında bir kaç gün geçti ve bana
Dediler ki:" bazı şirketlerin elli ve üstü
çalışan olan şirketlerin engelli
çalıştırma zorumluluğu var,
sen de engelli olduğun için
eğer rapörun varsa,
biz bunu değerlendirmek isteriz."dediler.
Ben bunu bilmiyordum,
Böyle bir şeyden hiç haberim yoktu.
Tamam dedim hemen işkur kaydı yapıldı.
Bende engelli kadrosunda
çalışmayı başladım.
Kendimi başka bir kadro da çalışacağımı,
zannediyordum aslında.
Hayır aynı görevemi devam ettim.
Analislik le başladım ve aynı
şeyi yapmayı devam ediyordum şirkette.
Sadece engelli kadrosun da yer alıyordum.
Şimdi bu benim aslında iş hayatında ki,
İlk dönem noktam oldu.
Ben bunu nasıl bilmiyorum.
Ben bir engelli olarak yeni mezun,
İş arayan biri olarak.
Bundan neden haberim yok
Biri beni bu konuda bilgilendirmelydi ve
neden bilgilendirilmedim?
kim bilgilendirmelydi diye,
kafamın arkasına bu soruyu işareteni,
aslında bir tohum olarak gömdüm.
Bunun bir cevapı yoktu şuan benim için.
Ama çok gerekli bir şey olduğunu düşündüm.
belki de böyle biri vardır ama
bana rast gelmemiştir diye düşündüm.
Sonrasında çalışma hayatına devam ettim.
Yoğun, koşuşturma, mesai ayrı.
Toplanda sekiz buçuk senelik iş hayatımda.
Yeresinden fazlasını son yeresinden,
fazlasını insan kaynakleri,
profesiyon olarak geçirdim.
Dört şirket değiştirdim ve tabi ki
Şirketleri değişirken,
iş görüşmelerini gidiyorsunuz.
Tatminsizlik olabiliyor iş le ilgili,
memnünyetsizlik olabiliyor.
Iş görüşmelerini gitiğimde de,
bu sefer de çok farklı,
bir taplo ila karşılaştım.
Şimdi engelli kadrosu olduğumu,
oğrendiğim için cvim de,
engelli olduğumu yazıyordu.
Görüşmeyi gitiğimde,
benim tecrübem le, yetkinliğim le,
nerden mezun olduğum la değil.
Aslında ilk önce
Engellim lie İlgileniyorlardı.
Bu benim için çok mantıksız bir şeydi.
Çünkü ben yapabileceğim işin peşindeydim.
Hangi sorumluluğu alabilirim?
Ne kadar sorumluluk alabilirim?
Hangi sektörlerdi?
Hangi pözüsüyonlar da çalışabilirim?
Ben bunları düşünüyordum.
Ama gittiğim zaman tedirgin biriyle,
karşılaşıyorum nasıl soracağını bilemiyor.
Yani ilginç sorular ve aslında
sorular la karşılaşabıiiyorsunuz.
Bu aşama da,İşte diyorlar ki
mesela"yani sakat mısınız şimdi ?"
Bunlar çok iyi şirketler bu arada.
Çok iyi şirketler de çalışanlar,
ilk ağcılar bunları soruyor.
"Işte sol tarafınız derken
Fol sol tarafınız mı hessetmiyor?
Yada kullanamıyorsunuz?
Yada bilgisayar kullanabiliyor musunuz ?"
Mesela.
Bu bir soru değil.
Çünkü Cvim de yazıyor, hangi bilgisayar
Programlarını kullandığım yazıyor zaten.
Ama maalesef cvyi okumuyorlar,
sadece engelli kısmını odaklanıyorlar.
Tek amaçları maalesef
engelli kadrolarını tamamlamak.
Sadece şirket kültürünü
uygun bir çalışan istiyorlar.
Pözüsüyon onlar için o an Kritik değil.
Benim için olduğu kadar en azından.
Onlarca iş görüşmesini gitmişimdir
mühtemelen ve gerçekten çoğunda
bunu yaşadım o garib bakışlar.
Hiç bir şeyi yaşamasam
değeşik bakışlar la karşılaştım.
Sanki ben kırılacakmışım gibi.
Böyle bıçak sırtı bir durumdaymiş gibi.
Rahat edemeyen ilk ağcılar,
Mulakatlar bu şekil de devam ediyor.
Tabi bende kendimi rahatsız,
hessetmeyi başladım, neden böyle oluyor?
Yani benim neden tecrübem le ve
yapmak istediğim şeyler le
İlgilenmiyorlar? diye .
Kafamın arkasını attığım tohum
yeşermeyi başladı.
Bunu neden kimseyi yapmıyor dedim.
Ben evet iş değiştirmek istiyorum,
çalışıyorum, öretiyorum.
Elimden geleni her şeyi yapıyorum,
sorumluk alıyorum.
Benim gibi çalışan,
Çok arkadaşım var engelli.
Şimdi onlara da bakıyorum.
Onlar çok daha dramatik şeyler
yaşayanlar var aralarında.
Bütün hikayeleri dinliyorum.
Diyorum ki:" neden bu konu da hiç
kimseyi yardım etmiyor,
bize destek olmuyor,
bir danışanımız yok, bize bu konu da,
yol gösterecek biri yok yada
İnsan kaynaklerina ulaşmadan önce
onları ulaşıp bizim le ilgili
bilgiyi verecek ve sadece teknik anlamda ki
detayleri değerlendirecek
bir görüşme yaşamıyoruz?.
Neden ön yargıyla karşılaşıyoruz?.
Engelli den değil de neden çalışabilir
biri akılla gelmiyor?.
Neden gerçekten sorumluk alabilen
İyi şirketler de çalışan iyi pözüsüyonları
gelecek birileri düşünülmiyor
engelli den diye zaman?"
Bu tohum yeşermeyi başladı.
Sonrasında iş hayatla devam ettim.
İlk ağ tarafı ağırlaşmayı başladı.
İlk ağ tarafında devam ederken de.
En sonda kendimi biraz daha
vakit ayırmayı başladım.
Kendimi yatırım yaptım
koştuk mentörluk eğetimleri aldım.
Kendime döndüm ve
şöyle bir farkındalığı ulaştım en sonunda.
Dedim ki:" bu tohum çok yeşerdi ve
benim bu tohumu yeşeretmek için
yeteri kadar malzemem vardı.
Ben bunu edendiğim tecrübe ile
İnsan kaynaklerini tecrübesiyle de
İnsan kaynaklerini tecrübesiyle de,
İyici büyütebilirim, solayıp gerçekten
çok büyük bir ağıç ve
orman yapabilirim dedim."
Bu ilham la kurumsal hayattan
ayrılıp istefa edip kendi şirketimi
olan Es kariyere kurdum.
Es kariyer sadece engelli
İstehtdami ile ilgili danışmanlık
veren bir şirket.
Hem işe alım hem mentörlük
hem koştuk tarafında
sadece engelli adaylarla çalışıyoruz.
Bu işe kurarken tabiki
bir çok istatiki veriyi de baktım.
Türkiye de on miliyon engelli var.
Bunların iki miliyon çalışabilir durumda.
Bu inanılmaz büyük bir pötensiyal demek.
Inanın o kadar çok kalıfeyi aday.
o kadar çok çalışır durumda.
Gerçekten sorumluk alabilen
ve çalışkan insanlar var ki
benim bile tahminim üstünde
gerçekten bu aramlar.
Böyle büyük bir pötansiyon la
değerlendirmek için içimdi güce inandım.
Zaten engelli bir çalışandım yıllarca
İnsan kaynakleri tarafında biliyorum.
Iş vereni ne beklediğini biliyorum.
Bu ölçü den yola çıkarak ta
ben bu işe yapabilirim dedim.
Çünkü o olgunlağı ileştim.
Fikrim evet yeşerdi büyüdü.
Ama ben bunu yapabilecek te durumdayım,
aynı zamanda diye
Bunu inandım kendimi inandım
Ve kendi şirketimi kurdum.
Başladığımda tek kişiydim.
Su dan çıkmış balıksınız.
Düşünseneze sosyal bir girişme
imza atıyorsunuz ve tek başınasınız.
Bu arada koskeb tan hibe alan
bir ellin parmağını geçmeyen
engelli kadınlar dan bir tanesiyim.
Pröjem çok beğenildi çok desteklediler
gerçekten bu anlamda beni.
Ama tek başımayım.
Bir kaç taneyi ilk ağcı arkadaşım la
çalışmayı başladım.
Sektör den tanıdığım,
üniveristen tanıdığım.
Sonrasında o kadar inanarak
o kadar severek yaptım ki her şeyi.
Büyüdüm.
Es kariyer şuan da yaklaşık
üçüncü senesini giriyor.
Türkiyenin en büyük ve önünde gelen
yaklaşık atmış şirket ile çalışıyorum.
Çok güzel bir ekepim var.
Onlarca adayı işe yerleştirdim
Ve ekipim de yüz le kırk engelli.
Burada aslında şöyle de bir nokta var.
Sadece bir fikir bulmanız cesaret le
o fikiri uygulamayı koymanız ve
devam etmeniz yetmiyor.
Sürdürebilir olmasını sağlamanız,
gerekiyor aynı zamanda.
Benim sürdürebilir den kastımdı.
O işe inanarak yaptığınız,
kısmından sonra o misiyon ve vizyona göre
İlerleyebiliyor olmanız.
Burada devamlılığı sağlamak için.
Hem ekipimiz engelli,
hem inanılmaz derece de fazla
sosyal sorumluklar la birlikte
Gönüllü olarak ta,
bir çok işte çalışıyoruz ve
gittkçe de büyüyürüz belki tüm türkiyeye.
Sonrasında dünyayı hizmet vereceğız,
çünkü türkiye de de dünyada da.
Böyle bir engelli danışmanlık şirket,
maalesef hala yok.
Sadece biz varız.
İlk başlarken anlatığım şeyi,
aslında geri döndüğümde.
Karşılaştığım zor bir durum karşısında.
Aklıma gelen bir şeyi tohum olarak ekmem
Sonrasında onu büyüterek yeni fikirler le
Yeni bakış açılıyra besleyip en sonda
Olgunlaştığında da.
Kendi kendimi adım atmaya,
Karar vermem le gelişiyordum bu sureç.
andria gessnin bir tani lafı var der ki:"
Kanatlarınızı açmadan ne kadar
büyük olduğunu bilemezsiniz."
Lütfen kendinizi inanın
ve sizde kanatlarını açın.
Teşekkür ederim.